if we look at the world today
how can we ensure that
the beautiful parts of nature
remain a big part of our lives
as human beings
and in the way we think about it in the
way
we also keep it around preserve it
you know we keep it part of our minds
and part of our world
it's a
very difficult question
because
every time there is a conflict between
conservation of a natural habitat
and
allowing people to
get a little bit of extra food for their
babies
then
naturally
the tendency is for the humans to win
so we have this steady
erosion
in the face of
tremendous efforts to conserve nature we
have a
continuing steady erosion of habitats
and all the species and the numbers are
always in the wrong direction
occasionally you get sort of wonderful
little examples of something being saved
but
the overall trend is clear
and it's very difficult to see how one
can ever escape that because
it's not human
i know that we are essentially a single
tribe
to
uh want to save an elephant if it means
killing 20 humans
so i think the only way in which we can
really conserve
is if we uh put
tremendous effort
into
conserving
the very best representative
areas of nature
often this will be the national parks
that already exist
and what we have to do is to make them
so valuable that actually it is worth it
in terms of human survival to be able to
keep those sorts of places
and
you know that's the attitude that uh
my colleagues and i have taken in uganda
where uh we want to
uh
keep the kibani national park alive
which has got the largest population
chimpanzees in uganda and it's got
elephants and wonderful birds and
wonderful butterflies and wonderful
plants and so on
and um and visitors
and lots and lots of visitors it may be
that we're going to have to have
huge increases in the amount of
charges that you pay for
and you need to make sure the ecotourism
is done right
in other places you will
keep nature there because it's useful
for
maintaining the climate
bringing rain
maybe
you can in some places
uh convince people of the sheer sort of
aesthetics of keeping nature
that
even over the long term
presidents whose job it is
to look for the future of the country
will be persuaded that you can do it for
purely aesthetic reasons
but overall
what is required
is for people in the rich countries
to do much more investment than
they have so far
in maintaining both
the natural places in their own
countries
and in the tropics and if you look at
africa you know i mean
the population trends are that
nigeria
may become the most populous country uh
in the world i think within a century
um
the
future of african habitats you know it's
clear what's going to happen in general
there's going to be a huge conversion
towards agricultural land
i heard
ed wilson
speak years ago about the prospect of
the entire globe being turned into a
single human feedlot
it's going to take a lot to avoid that
he is out there
calling for
half the earth
to be devoted to nature
it's incredibly ambitious and incredibly
optimistic
but unless you have
really exciting goals
probably nothing will be achieved
yeah i mean there's something um
to me like when i visit new york and i
see central park and somehow constructed
a situation where you preserve this park
in the middle
probably some of the most expensive land
in the world
the fact that that's possible gives me
hope that you can do this kind of
preservation at a global scale
uh perhaps for just the aesthetic
reasons of just valuing
the beauty and um
disrespecting our origins
of having come from the earth
we are so incredibly lucky
to have
chimpanzees bonobos and gorillas as our
um close relatives still living on the
earth you know we're unlucky that we
don't have australopithecines and other
species of homo
but we're still lucky to have those
because they are incredibly closely
related to us compared to what most
animals have you know there are many
animals that don't have any close
relatives to them on the earth but not
only are they they're relatively close
but they teach us so much about
ourselves you know they the similarities
between them and ourselves raise
questions that we can then test
about the extent to which our own
behavioral propensities are derived from
the same evolutionary stock as in those
great apes
well how much is that worth you know i
mean we could spend billions going to
the
mars to
find
evidence of bacteria there and that's
fascinating too
but we should be spending billions on
this earth in order to
make sure
that we have
i don't know how to say it you know
substantial representative populations
are these close relatives
yeah that we can meet there's something
um like space tourism when you go out
into space and you look back down on
earth
that's to a lot of people including
myself is worth a lot but why is that
worth a lot is because you uh
it's humbling
and
beautiful
in the same way that meeting our close
evolutionary relatives is humble and
beautiful
just to know that this
this is what we come from this is who we
are
not just for the understanding or the
science of it but just like something
about just the beauty of witnessing this
um and it's again it's both humbling and
empowering
that this place is fragile and we're
damn lucky to be here
yes unfortunately the problems are
incredibly difficult
to solve and there is no one solver you
know it has to happen from a network of
potentially cooperating people
but but i mean you're so right about it
being daunting to to think about what it
looks like from space and i love the
view that herman muller expressed
of
being able to go out from space and he
said the whole of life
would look like a kind of rust on the
planet
you